♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
TONIGHT, WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS
ON NUMEROUS BIG STORIES.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO IN BIG
TROUBLE AFTER A BOMBSHELL NEW
REPORT REVEALED THAT CUOMO
ATTEMPTED A COVER-UP, THE
NURSING HOME DEATH TOLL RELATED
TO HIS DISASTROUS COVID-19
POLICY.
SOME ARE NOW CALLING FOR CUOMO
TO BE PROSECUTED FOR OBSTRUCTION
OBSTRUCTION, EVEN HAVE FAKE NEWS
CNN FAKE JAKE TAPPER, HE’S
ACTUALLY COVERING WITH SCANDAL,
TWEETING TODAY, "THE STORY KEEPS
GETTING WORSE FOR ANDREW CUOMO."
WE ARE GOING TO UPDATE YOU ON
MORE WITH THIS DEVELOPING STORY
AND GIVE THE LATEST FROM THE
MULTIPLE SCANDALS NOW ROCKING
THE ANTI-TRUMP LINCOLN PROJECT.
NOW IN COMPLETE MELTDOWN MODE.
MEGHAN McCAIN, WOW, UNLEASHED
BRUTAL TWEETS TONIGHT.
ONE OF THEIR CONE FOUNDERS,
STEVE SCHMIDT, JUST RESIGNED IN
DISGRACE.
BUT FIRST, THE DEMOCRATS SNAP
IMPEACHMENT CHARADE SHAM, IT
JUST FACED ITS DAY OF RECKONING.
FINALLY, THE PRESIDENT’S LEGAL
DEFENSE TEAM, THEY COMPLETELY
EVISCERATED ALL OF THE DEMOCRATS
PAPER-THIN ARGUMENTS, ALL OF
WHICH WERE, AS WE TOLD YOU,
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
NONE OF WHICH MEET ANY REAL
LEGAL STANDARD THAT WOULD EVER
HOLD UP IN ANY COURT.
NO RULES OF EVIDENCE MATTER IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE, MATTER, OR FORM,
AND TO ADD TO THAT, THEY ARE
EDITING, SLICING, DICING, AND
THEN PURPOSELY IGNORING ALL
DAMAGING, EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE,
AND PRESIDED OVER BY A JUDGE WHO
ALREADY DECLARED TRUMP GUILTY.
WOW.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THAT’S A KANGAROO COURT.
THE HOUSE MANAGERS, THEY WERE
EVISCERATED ON THEIR ARGUMENT
OVER INCITEMENT.
THEIR FAVORITE WORD,
INSURRECTION.
THEY WERE EVISCERATED ON THEIR
ARGUMENT OF THE CONSTITUTION,
THE PRESIDENT’S DEFENSE TEAM
EXPOSED TO MANAGERS’
MANUFACTURED, SELECTIVE EDITING,
AND EXPOSE THE DEMOCRATS RAMPANT
HYPOCRISY.
IT WAS A HUMILIATING, TOTAL,
COMPLETE BEAT DOWN.
NOW THE DEFENSE TEAM STARTED
TODAY BY SHOWING HOW THE
IMPEACHMENT MANAGERS ACTUALLY
HAD TO MANIPULATE AND DID
MANIPULATE THE PRESIDENT’S
JANUARY 6TH REMARKS.
WATCH FOR YOURSELF.
>> WE ARE GOING TO WALK DOWN,
AND I WILL BE THERE WITH YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO WALK DOWN -- WE
ARE GOING TO WALK DOWN TO THE
CAPITAL.
WE ARE GOING TO WALK DOWN TO THE
CAPITOL.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CHEER ON OUR
BRAVE SENATORS AND CONGRESSMEN
AND WOMEN, AND WE ARE PROBABLY
NOT GOING TO BE CHEERING SO MUCH
FOR SOME OF THEM.
BECAUSE YOU’LL NEVER TAKE BACK
OUR COUNTRY WITH WEAKNESS.
YOU HAVE TO SHOW STRENGTH, AND
YOU HAVE TO BE STRONG.
WE HAVE COME TO DEMAND THAT
CONGRESS DO THE RIGHT THING AND
ONLY COUNT THE ELECTORS WHO HAVE
BEEN LAWFULLY SLATED.
LAWFULLY SLATED.
I KNOW THAT EVERYONE HERE WILL
SOON BE MARCHING OVER TO THE
CAPITOL BUILDING.
TO PEACEFULLY AND PATRIOTICALLY
MAKE YOUR VOICES HEARD.
>> Sean: NOW, AS YOU COULD
SEE, NOT ONLY DID THE DEMOCRATS
SELECTIVELY EDIT THE PRESIDENT’S
SPEECH, THEY ALSO MANIPULATED
KEY EVIDENCE, PIECES OF
EVIDENCE, AND THEY FREQUENTLY
RELIED ON, GUESS WHAT, WELL,
THEIR BEST FRIEND, SKETCHY NEWS
REPORTS AND RUMOR TO MAKE THEIR
CASE.
I WOULD NEVER FLY IN EVERY COURT
OF LAW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ACCORDING TO THOSE AROUND
HIM, AT THE TIME, REPORTEDLY
RESPONDED -- TRUMP REPORTEDLY
REPORTS.
>> CROSS MAJOR NEWS NETWORKS,
INCLUDING FOX NEWS, REPORTED --
>> REPORTEDLY --
>> REPORTEDLY, NOT ACCIDENTAL.
>> ACCORDING TO REPORTS, --
>> SPOKE TO THE GUARD.
>> ACCORDING TO REPORTS.
>> REPORTEDLY.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHY, AS
JONATHAN TURLEY WARNED THE
COUNTRY, YOU DO NOT DO SNAP
IMPEACHMENTS.
THIS IS WHY YOU ACTUALLY NEED
REAL TIME THAT YOU’VE GOT TO
TAKE SO YOU CAN GATHER REAL
EVIDENCE, SO YOU CAN CONDUCT
THOROUGH INVESTIGATIONS, ALLOW
DUE PROCESS, AND EVEN, OH, THE
THOUGHT OF IT, ALLOW FOR A
DEFENSE.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS CASE RESTS ON
TWO INCREDIBLY FLAWED AND
EXTREMELY WEAK ARGUMENTS.
NOW THE FIRST, THAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID "FIGHT LIKE HELL"
AND THOSE WORDS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE, AND THEY INCITED
AN INSURRECTION ON JANUARY 6
FROM THE PRESIDENT’S RALLY.
AS THE PRESIDENT’S LAWYERS
RIGHTLY POINTED OUT TODAY, IN
WHAT BECAME A TEN MINUTE
STRAIGHT MONTAGE SHOWING
DEMOCRATS THEMSELVES FREQUENTLY
USING THIS PHRASE, "FIGHT LIKE
HELL" OR "FIGHT, FIGHT, FIGHT"
IN FRONT OF THEIR OWN
SUPPORTERS.
HYPOCRISY ON DISPLAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE CAN FIND OR WE CAN FIGHT
BACK.
I AM HERE TO FIGHT BACK.
I AM HERE TO FIGHT BACK!
>> BUT WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS FIGHT DOES NOT END
TONIGHT.
>> THIS IS A FIGHT FOR OUR
LIVES.
>> I WILL FIGHT LIKE HELL TO
FIGHT BACK AGAINST ANYONE.
>> WE NEED TO SAY LOUD AND CLEAR
THAT WE ARE READY TO FIGHT.
>> A BARE KNUCKLES FIGHT.
>> NOW THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
ACTUALLY FIGHT BACK.
>> WE ARE GOING TO FIGHT BACK,
NOT JUST TAKE THIS LYING DOWN.
>> WHAT WE HAVE TO DO RIGHT NOW
AS FIGHT AS HARD AS WE CAN.
>> WE HAVE TO RISE UP AND FIGHT
BACK.
>> CONTINUE TO FIGHT.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE A FIGHT.
>> WE WILL FIGHT HIM AND
CHALLENGE HIM ANYWAY WE CAN.
>> THIS IS OUR FIGHT RIGHT NOW.
>> THERE’S A FIGHT --
>> THERE’S THE FIGHT --
>> THEN THERE’S THE FIGHT TO
DEFEND.
>> JUST HAVE TO SAY THIS IS A
FIGHT FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: SO BASED ON THE
DEMOCRATS DEFINITION, ALL OF
THEM WERE INCITING INSURRECTION.
IF THAT’S WHAT YOU BELIEVE,
EVERY DEMOCRAT WOULD BE GUILTY
BY THEIR OWN STANDARD.
WHAT IS THEIR STANDARD?
AND WHAT ABOUT THEIR VIOLENT
RHETORIC?
DOESN’T COUNT AS INCITEMENT TO
INSURRECTION?
AS AS ALWAYS ON THE SHOW, WE
WILL LET YOU DECIDE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AND UPRISING.
MAYBE THERE WILL BE.
>> THERE NEEDS TO BE UNREST IN
THE STREETS FOR AS LONG AS THERE
IS UNREST IN OUR LIVES.
>> WE HAVE TO BE READY TO THROW
A PUNCH.
>> DONALD TRUMP, I THINK YOU
NEED TO GO BACK AND PUNCH HIM IN
THE FACE.
>> I THOUGHT THEY SHOULD’VE
PUNCHED HIM IN THE FACE.
>> PUNCHING HIM.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE HIM
BEHIND THE GYM AND FIGHT HIM.
>> IF I WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL, I
WOULD TAKE THE GYM AND BEAT THE
SPEED 24 OUT OF 10.
>> FIBER AND HIGH SCHOOL, I
WOULD TAKE IN BEHIND THE GYM.
>> TAKE THEM OUT NOW.
>> WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME AN
ACTOR ASSASSINATED A PRESIDENT.
>> ANYMORE, ANY ANYWHERE.
>> I THOUGHT AN AWFUL LOT ABOUT
BLOWING UP THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> GET IN THE FACE OF THE
CONGRESSPEOPLE.
>> I WANT TO TELL YOU, GORSUCH,
I WANT TO TELL YOU, KAVANAUGH,
YOU HAVE RELEASED A WHIRLWIND,
AND HE WILL PAY THE PRICE.
>> Sean: "YOU WILL PAY THE
PRICE WAS PUT!
OKAY, AS YOU ALL KNOW NOW, IT
WASN’T JUST DEMOCRATS SPEWING
VIOLENT RHETORIC, BUT THEIR PALS
AND ALLIES, THEIR PRESS OFFICES
IN THE MEDIA MOB.
2019, "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
JENNIFER RUBIN CALLING THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, CALLING FOR IT
TO BE BURNED TO THE GROUND.
"WE HAVE TO LEVEL THEM BECAUSE
IF THERE ARE SURVIVORS, IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO WEATHERED THE
STORM, THEY WILL DO IT AGAIN."
AFTER YEARS OF THIS TYPE OF
RHETORIC, THERE WAS A WAVE OF
FAR LEFT POLITICAL VIOLENCE.
WE ALL WATCHED IT WITH SADNESS
AND HORROR ALL SUMMER.
MOST DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA,
COMPLETELY SILENT, IN COMPLETE
DENIAL.
THE SILENCE WAS DEAFENING.
THE LACK OF JUST COUNTING
REALITY BEFORE THEIR VERY EYES.
ONE YEAR OF RIOTS, THE
DEMOCRATS, THE MEDIA MOB, OH,
NOW FINALLY, THEY ARE TELLING
YOU THEY CARE ABOUT RIOTING.
WELL, WE SHOULD ALL CONDEMN,
THIS SHOULDN’T BE POLITICAL, ALL
THESE RIOTS, ANY VIOLENCE,
WHATEVER IT TAKES PLACE, AND
YES, EVERY CONSERVATIVE
CONDEMNED WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
CAPITAL.
IN FACT, IN MANY CASES, YOU HAD
DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING
THIS SUMMERS RIOTS.
WATCH FOR YOURSELF.
>> THEY ARE NOT GOING TO STOP,
AND EVERYONE BE AWARE.
>> SOME OF THE DAMAGE PEOPLE
WILL BE WAKING UP TO.
>> I’M PROUD OF NEW YORK, AND
I’M PROUD OF THE PROTESTS.
>> THERE IS DAMAGE EVERYWHERE
YOU LOOK.
HONESTLY, IT LOOKS LIKE A
WAR ZONE.
>> HEARTWARMING TO SEE SO MANY
PEOPLE TURN OUT PEACEFULLY.
>> THEY KEEP DOING IT DAY AFTER
DAY AFTER DAY.
A NATION OF QUALITY PROTESTS.
THE PATRIOTS OR PROTESTERS.
>> ST. JOHN’S CHURCH IS ON FIRE.
>> I HOPE SOMEONE BURNS DOWN
YOUR WHOLE PRECINCT WITH ALL OF
YOU ALL INSIDE.
>> NOT GENERALLY SPEAKING
UNRULY.
>> Sean: THIS SUMMER, THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES KAMALA HARRIS EVEN
PROMOTED THE BAIL FUND FOR
RIOTERS ARRESTED, SAYING "GET
BACK OUT AND JOIN THEIR
FRIENDS, I GUESS.
CAN YOU IMAGINE IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP EVER DID THIS.
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM RAISED A
POWERFUL QUESTION EARLIER TODAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES A POLITICIAN RAISING
VEIL FOR RIOTERS ENCOURAGE MORE
RIOTING?
>> COUNSEL HAS 5 MINUTES.
>> YES.
>> Sean: IF DONALD TRUMP
INCITED VIOLENCE AND
INSURRECTION, THEN SO DID PRETTY
MUCH EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THIS
COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS, AND IF
THE DEMOCRATIC MANAGERS, IF THEY
APPLIED THEIR SAME STANDARDS TO
KAMALA HARRIS AND OTHER
DEMOCRATS, THEY SHOULD ALL BE
IMPEACHED AND THEY SHOULD ALL BE
TRIED, INCLUDING JOE BIDEN.
THE GUY THAT WANTS TO TAKE TRUMP
TO THE BACK OF THE GYM, THEN
PRESIDENT, AND BEAT THE HELL OUT
ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IS THAT NOT INCITEMENT TO
INSURRECTION?
NOW, SO ARE THEIR CLAIMS ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT’S RHETORIC, THE
SAME THING.
THEY WANT YOU TO BELIEVE HIS
STATEMENTS ABOUT ELECTION
IRREGULARITIES AND VOTER FRAUD,
THAT IT CAUSED VIOLENCE ON
JANUARY 6TH.
YOU KNOW, WHEN HE SAID MANY OF
YOU WILL MARCH TO THE CAPITAL
PEACEFULLY AND PATRIOTICALLY SO
YOUR VOICES CAN BE HEARD?
BUT IF THAT IS THE CASE, WELL,
PLEASE DEMOCRATS, ARE THEY GOING
TO BE IMPEACHED?
ARE WE GOING TO PUT
SENATOR JOHN THUNE, ARE WE GOING
TO PUT THEM ON TRIAL, SHOULD
THEY BE CENSORED TOO?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OF STACEY ABRAMS NOT WIN IN
GEORGIA, HE STOLE IT, IT’S
CLEAR.
I SAY THAT PUBLICLY, IT’S CLEAR.
>> YOU CAN RUN THE BEST
CAMPAIGN, YOU CAN EVEN BECOME
THE NOMINEE.
AND YOU CAN HAVE THE ELECTION
STOLEN FROM YOU.
>> HE KNOWS HE IS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
>> HE KNOWS, HE KNOWS THAT THERE
WERE A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
REASONS WHY THE ELECTION TURNED
OUT THE WAY IT DID.
>> VOTES REMAIN TO BE COUNTED.
THERE ARE VOICES THAT ARE
WAITING TO BE HEARD.
>> AND I WILL NOT CONCEDE.
>> I RESPECT WHERE YOU ARE
COMING FROM AND I RESPECT THE
ISSUES YOU ARE RAISING.
YOU ARE NOT ANSWERING THE
QUESTION.
>> I AM --
>> YOU ARE NOT USING THE WORD
LEGITIMATE.
>> THERE ARE STILL LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS OVER THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTIONS AND OF ENSURING
THE PRINCIPLE OF ONE PERSON, ONE
VOTE.
>> Sean: TODAY’S PRESENTATION
WAS SO COMPELLING, SO DAMNING,
THE DEMOCRATS WERE FORCED TO
RETURN TO THEIR FAVORITE SMEAR,
THEY ACCUSE THE PRESIDENT LEGAL
TEAM OF RACISM AND SEXISM.
YEP, TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE DEFENSE COUNSEL PUT A LOT
OF VIDEOS OUT IN THERE -- IN
THEIR DEFENSE.
PLAYING CLIP AFTER CLIP OF BLACK
WOMEN TALKING ABOUT FIGHTING FOR
A CAUSE OR AN ISSUE OR A POLICY.
IT WAS NOT LOST ON ME, SO MANY
OF THEM WERE PEOPLE OF COLOR,
AND WOMEN, BLACK WOMEN.
BLACK WOMEN LIKE MYSELF, WHO ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF BEING SICK AND
TIRED FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THIS SUMMER, THINGS HAPPENED
THAT WERE VIOLENT.
BUT THERE WERE ALSO THINGS THAT
GAVE SOME OF US BLACK WOMEN
GREAT COMFORT.
>> Sean: OFTEN, WHEN DEMOCRATS
TURNED TO IDENTITY POLITICS,
KIND OF MEANS THEY LOST THE
ARGUMENT.
EARLIER TODAY, HERE IS WHAT
SENATOR RON JOHNSON HAD TO SAY,
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S
LAWYERS BLEW THE HOUSE MANAGER’S
CASE OF THE WATER.
THEY LEGALLY EVISCERATED THEM.
I THINK THEIR ARGUMENTS, WHEN
THEY SHOW THE DISTORTION OF THE
TWEETS, THE SELECTED EDITING,
SHOW THE REASON WHY DUE PROCESS
IS IMPORTANT.
AND IT CERTAINLY PROVED THAT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT APPLIES TO
POLITICAL SPEECH, PROBABLY MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
SO YEAH, I THINK THE PRESIDENT’S
LAWYERS JUST BLEW THE HOUSE
MANAGER CASE OUT OF THE WATER.
>> Sean: AS YOU CAN IMAGINE,
THE MEDIA, THE MOB, WAS NOT
TAKING TODAY’S EVISCERATION VERY
WELL.
IN FACT, THEY WERE SO UPSET BY
THE FACTS OF THE CASE AMID A
MULTITUDE OF COMPLAINTS THEY
DECIDED EVEN TO ATTACK YOURS
TRULY.
HOW DID MY NAME GET BROUGHT UP
IN THIS LITTLE EVENT?
>> WHILE TITILLATING AND SURELY
SATISFYING TO VIEWERS OF
RIGHT-WING MEDIA, NONE OF IT
DEFENDED THE TRAGIC CONSEQUENCE
OF DONALD TRUMP SPEECH.
>> I HOPE AND TRUST YOU HAVE
NEVER USED THE WORD FIGHT IN A
LIVE REPORT, AS YOU WILL BE PART
OF THE AFTERNOON MONTAGE.
>> THIS PRESENTATION IS VERY
PARTISAN.
IT WAS A SEAN HANNITY MIX TAPE.
>> ALMOST LITERALLY.
>> WHAT WE SAW TIMMY WAS A
PREVIEW OF "HANNITY" TONIGHT,
AND IT REALLY DID SEEM TO BE
TRYING TO MAKE THIS AS MUCH OF A
PARTISAN PROCESS AS POSSIBLE.
>> BECAUSE LONG VIDEO CLIPS, SO
MANY OF THEM THAT WE HAVE SEEN,
YOU KNOW, "HANNITY" AND OTHER
SHOWS ON FOX.
>> AND THE VIDEO PRESENTATION,
GRATUITOUS, OVER-THE-TOP,
REPETITIVE ABOUT DEMOCRATS USING
THE WORD "FIGHT," WAS THAT MEANT
TO DO?
NUMBER ONE, MAKE THE CLIENT
HAPPY.
>> Sean: THE TRUTH THAT THEY
WON’T TELL.
THEIR AUDIENCES TODAY, PROBABLY
MANY OF THEM, SEEING THEIR OWN
WORDS IN THE MEDIA, AND THE
DEMOCRATS, OH, INCITEMENT TO
INSURRECTION.
THAT IS WHY THIS PROGRAM IS
INDEPENDENT.
THIS IS WHY WE DON’T RUSH TO
JUDGMENT.
IT’S WHY WE CONDUCT OUR OWN
INVESTIGATIONS AND WE PROVIDE
IMPORTANT CONTEXT.
THAT IS WHY WE GOT IT RIGHT AND
THEY GOT IT WRONG ON THE RUSSIA
HOAX.
THE DUKE LACROSSE CASE, UBA,
CAVANAUGH, FERGUSON, CAMBRIDGE
POLICE, BALTIMORE, THE COMING
IN TEN HIGH SCHOOL KIDS, THE
MEDIA MOB GOT IT WRONG AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
THEY RUSH TO JUDGMENT ON GET IT
WRONG.
THEY DO IT EVERY DAY.
EVERY TIME, WE WERE RIGHT, THEY
WERE WRONG, EVERY SINGLE TIME.
THAT’S THE SAME GOING TO THIS
SNAP IMPEACHMENT PEERLESS COMES
ONTO THREE FACTS, ONE, SENATE
HAS NO JURISDICTION
OVER A PRIVATE U.S. CITIZEN AND
CANNOT REMOVE PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM AN OFFICE HE DOES NOT HOLD.
TWO, ACCORDING TO THE FBI AND
DOJ, COURT DOCUMENTS, AOC, AND
EVEN THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA
OUTLETS, THE ATTACK ON
JANUARY 6TH WAS PREPLANNED.
THE PRESIDENT’S REMARKS,
THEREFORE, DID NOT INCITE AN
INSURRECTION.
THAT WAS PLANNED AHEAD OF TIME.
NOW, A SMALL PERCENTAGE, MAYBE
1%, OF RALLY ATTENDEES SADLY
PARTICIPATE?
YEP, AND THEY WILL ALL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND THREE, IF THE WORD LIKE
"FIGHT LIKE HELL" AND "ELECTION
CHALLENGE" IS NOT GROUNDS FOR
IMPEACHMENT, THAN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ARE IN A LOT OF TROUBLE.
THE SNAP IMPEACHMENT SCHIFF SHOW
CHARADE WILL BE OVER, THE
PRESENT WILL BE ACQUITTED AS HE
SHOULD BE COMMENDED IN THE
COMING MONTHS, DEMOCRATS WILL BE
FORCED TO ANSWER FOR THEIR
OWN CONDUCT.
THE HEIGHT OF A PANDEMIC,
MILLIONS OUT OF WORK, MILLIONS
MORE SUFFERING, DEMOCRATS CHOSE
A POLITICAL SHOW TRIAL AS THEIR
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY.
IN THE MIDTERMS, I HOPE YOU
REMEMBER THAT.
YOU NOW NEED TO KNOW THIS, AS
WELL.
TO VOTE RASKIN AND SWALLOW WELL
AND WARREN AND PRETTY MUCH EVERY
OTHER DEMOCRAT, SCHUMER AND JOE
AND KAMALA AND PELOSI,’S FIGHT L
AS PART REPUBLICAN SENATORS LIKE
SENATOR JOHN TUNE, REPORTEDLY
OPEN TO CONTINUING THIS CHARADE
WITH A CENSURE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, ANY REPUBLICAN
THAT VOTES TO KEEP VALIDATING
AND LEGITIMIZING THIS MADNESS
WHILE NEVER, EVER, JOHN THUNE,
HAVING THE COURAGE TO EVER APPLY
THESE EXACT SAME STANDARDS TO
YOUR COLLEAGUES ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, HE WOULD NEED
TO BE PRIMARIED, AND WHEN DID
JOHN THUNE EVER LIFT A FINGER TO
HELP EXPOSE THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
HOAX?
I DON’T REMEMBER.
ANYWAY, ANY REPUBLICAN, YOU ARE
GOING TO APPLY THESE STANDARDS,
ANY MORE OF THIS, TO
DONALD TRUMP, APPLY IT TO JOE,
KAMALA, CHUCK, MAXINE WATERS,